[Music]
the real housewives of atlanta
to meeting the fabulous conan yes i was
so excited when i got the call to do a
small party for him
so what time is he supposed to be he
should be here any minute oh you know
cool i don't want to press in
excuse me excuse me are you with conan
yeah you do you're trying you you are
oh my god where's conan conan definitely
wanted to be here but i think
they said that conan was supposed to be
here and conan isn't here i don't like
this i was saying specifically that i
was going to do a luncheon for him for
the girls come today
we are sending a representative from the
show
yes we we actually do have some on
camera talent coming down in just a
little bit yes
look at this room
i haven't seen a shirt all this big
since kirstie alley bent over to pick up
a seashell
i invite the girl's over i'm thinking
i'm doing this conan party and this
jerk dog shows up with this cigar i mean
it was it was just not classy
okay where's the one people know
nene where is he
he's the one people now oh my god i i
really am excited i mean you're all
reality tv stars oh thank you
it must be exciting to be almost as
famous as pawn shop employees
and that lady who's addicted to eating
sofa cushions because you you need to
get your facts together
30 seconds i got this i'm very known on
the show so show some respect let's talk
about it let's get them let's get this
this is what the people want
now kenya
you wanted to help phaedra produce a
workout video and phaedra thought you
wanted too much money and so then you
made your own competing workout video
with a very similar name so she said
that you stole the idea so here's my
question
who gives a [ __ ]
no people care people people care a lot
of people
watch the show lonely angry spinsters
looking for someone to feel superior to
transvestites watch the show looking for
fashion tips
of course your relatives who don't like
it but feel obligated to watch okay
people are stuck in various waiting
rooms obviously you can't watch this
show enough to know my reputation this
is this is my husband's place so you're
not going to come in here and poop on me
it's hard to poop on you because you are
the classiest well thank you you are the
classiest of the real housewives which
is sort of like saying you're the
smartest kardashian
oh my god
like really how are you going to be a
male dog who's really a [ __ ] with no
balls and then you want to talk [ __ ] to
us
sweetheart now this is another
controversy
candy you're suing the crazy blonde
[ __ ] kim
for uh
target okay we are not giving him his
cigar back
i'm gonna hold your cigarette for you
candy you
are suing
kim
because you say you wrote tardy for the
party
for the party
for the party
candy is multi-talented first target for
the party
and now a line of sex toys it is amazing
how much you can get done when you don't
stop to feel deeply ashamed of yourself
isn't it
i like bringing joy to people's lives so
let's see let's see the sex toy
see oh wait now get a shot of that i'm
gonna sue you for that because that is
an exact replica of my penis
no great craftsmanship i admire it from
a chinese toddler's hands to your
bedroom folks
oh no
this one over here
tell me again who you are and why i
should despise you
[Laughter]
i know triumph should be named trouble
because he is nothing but trouble he
insulted us all can you you help me out
here okay i hope you we're gonna look at
look a little bit at phaedra's workout
video okay now look at this our jesus
christ it's gonna be our disco lady and
we're gonna start that off with the legs
you ready
three times certified best shot
hell yeah and i'll tell you what else
this video shows people that with a
little hard work you can achieve your
dream of being somewhat out of shape
well i was three months pregnant
i know not the best timing
now look at this
look at this on amazon fine body workout
video i saw this on amazon now you
scroll down and it said people who
bought this also bought
big bags
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's talk about your video the gun with
the wind fabulous let's open the video
you say i'm fake
i say i'm fabulous you say i'm old
i say i'm fabulous i'm gone with the
wind fabulous i'm gone with the wind
fabulous yeah
gone with the wind fabulous
maybe more like silence of the lambs
fabulous
mr dog okay my song was number 38 on
itunes on day one i know and you know
what now i understand now it's number
one in guantanamo
number one somewhere
in guantanamo and so your song is
appropriate
oh we're having fun right we're having a
great time okay
it's a fun game in that song it's like
you say i'm fabulous no matter what
right so exactly i say i'm fabulous no
matter what you say about it that's
exactly so if i say you're completely
insane you say i say i'm fabulous if i
say you have no place recording a pop
song with your lack of talent you say i
say i'm fabulous if i say this song
is such a horrible soul-deadening piece
of crap it should only be listened to in
the presence of a suicide hotline
counselor
you say
i say i'm fabulous now if i say please
stop doing this do not make any more
music this isn't even a joke i'm begging
you again okay look listen i just have
one more joke yeah it's kenya and you
have said my name raw more than one time
today i'm sorry you've wanted something
i'm crazy i'm gonna give you crazy troy
barbie
with you this is a reality tv show yes
it is i hear your breathing will be all
over your ass here's a little reality
for you you're going to have a very
lightly attended funeral well you know
as long as you're not there
oh yeah i'm not going to be there
don't you worry about me i put my hand
anywhere i want to put that little thug
dog tram thought he was going to come in
here and mess with the queen bee but he
got another thing coming because i am
gone with the wind fabulous
that's kenya
[Applause]